erst haben cdu und csu den
wahlkampfstart verstolpert dann die
bündnisgrünen also zweite chance für die
unions-parteien und da soll jetzt nichts
mehr anbrennen
die gebrauchsanweisung dazu steht auf
140 seiten und lenzens wahlprogramm von
kritikern als wohlfühl angebot
gescholten soll es in erster linie einen
starken kontrast zum politischen
hauptgegner bilden das etikett verbots
partei für die bündnisgrünen würde armin
laschet vieles erleichtern
nach dem 26 september allerdings muss
abgerüstet werden zumal wenn
schwarz-grün unausweichlich erscheint
fidele zeiten wahlprogramm auf dem tisch
kann schwarz mit grün jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst ihrem studio
wird der hasselmann ist bei uns die
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
der bündnisgrünen im bundestag
christoph ploß ist ebenfalls im
bundestag für die cdu sie zählen zum
konservativen flügel ihrer partei und
sie sind auch erklärtermaßen kein großer
freund von koalitionen mit den grünen
zugeschaltet ist frau professorin ursula
münch die direktorin der akademie für
politische bildung in tutzing und der
publizist und kolumnist der zeitschrift
cicero frank am main
herzlich willkommen bei uns so
hasselmann hat denn das wahlprogramm der
union dass da jetzt in dieser woche
veröffentlicht worden ist ihre vorfreude
auf ein schwarz grünes bündnis nochmals
gesteigert das wahlprogramm der cdu
liegt ja jetzt endlich vor es hat lange
gedauert
ich glaube damit waren große erwartungen
verbunden
trotzdem weiss nicht so recht noch
niemand wofür die cdu konkret kämpft in
diesem wahlkampf aber das wichtige ist
bei uns die konzentration auf unsere
grünen inhalte unser programm und unser
angebot an die bürgerinnen und bürger
und am ende entscheiden die ja darüber
wer am 27 september stärkste kraft wird
wir werden alles dafür geben diesmal aus
der ausgangsposition um platz eins mit
diesem angebot des programms deutschland
alles ist drin zu kämpfen
gute genau darauf achten wir jetzt auch
was der bürger dann entscheidet und was
diese entscheidung am 26 september dann
auch bedeutet für die parteien unter
anderem die sie hier vertreten hat los
die union will ja gar nicht mit den
grünen koalieren so hört man immer
wieder nicht nur von ihnen davon müssen
sie aber die wählerinnen und wähler noch
überzeugen ein reines bekenntnis nicht
mit bündnis grünen zu koalieren genügt
da nicht
ja so am ende kämpfen wir erstmal im
wahlkampf alle für uns selbst und für
unsere punkte und für unser programm und
ich werde mit sicherheit keinen
koalitionswahlkampf führen und schon gar
keinen koalitionswahlkampf der schwarz
grün lautet weil wir tatsächlich sehr
große unterschiede bei den
unterschiedlichen themen haben wir
wollen zum beispiel die wichtige frage
wie wir die pariser klimaschutzziele
erreichen marktwirtschaftlich
innovationsgetriebene und
technologieoffen angehen und das
unterscheidet uns von den grünen die vor
allem über verbote und über gängelung
kommen und das kann man auch bei vielen
anderen fragen sehen daher glaube ich
auch werden wir in den nächsten wochen
wenn es darum geht werden die grüne
nummer eins oder werden die
unionsparteien nummer eins noch sehr
viel zu sparen
gut das haben sie sicherlich nicht
exklusiv dass sie keinen
koalitionswahlkampf führen wollen das
wollen die bündnisgrünen und die anderen
parteien natürlich auch nicht warum man
sagt ja immer so schön papier ist
geduldig was da jetzt an wahlprogrammen
unter anderem von cdu csu und
bündnisgrünen veröffentlicht worden ist
kann man auch sagen da ist papier
geduldig das ist zunächst einmal
gedruckt was daraus wird ist eine ganz
andere frage
insgesamt kann man das schon zu sagen
also es ist zunächst mal viel lyrik
relativ allgemein aber für die
unterschiedlichen parteien erfüllt so
ein wahlprogramm natürlich schon
unterschiedliche zwecke die cdu und csu
waren noch nie programm parteien sind
keine ideologischen parteien die lassen
sich auch nicht so einfach auf dem
programm festnageln und tragen es
sicherlich auch mit fassung beide aber
wenn man ihn jetzt vorwirft verordnung
der politische gegner oder auch die
medien dass das alles zu unkonkret und
zu ungenau ist das ist jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten aber durchaus auch für
die grünen ein bisschen anders für die
erfüllt ein programm
dann schon eher den anspruch die eigene
wählerschaft die stammwähler aber auch
die wechselwähler stärker anzusprechen
also das sind schon eher parteien die
mit dieser problematik etwas konkretes
verbinden
und ich glaube so lassen sich durchaus
auch die unterschiede und auch die
unterschiedliche präzisions grat
zwischen grünen parteiprogramm oder
wahlprogrammen dem der cdu csu erklärt
ist ja so dass die wahlprogramme vor uns
sitzt der aktuelle aufhänger waren wir
wissen ja von dem einen oder anderen
politiker der politikerin dass sie die
eigenen wahlprogramme noch nicht mal
lesen wir uns trotzdem mit diesem thema
natürlich heute befassen
herr meyer der sogenannte realitätscheck
der kommt ja immer erst nach der
bundestagswahl werden denn da die
parteien bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
und später auch beim kassensturz
überhaupt doch vom über das überhaupt
noch herauskommen aus dem kröten
schlucken dass sie dann machen müssen um
über das zu verhandeln was dann
letztendlich sache ist und nicht das was
ich hier im wahlkampf alles versprochen
haben naja vielleicht muss man sagen ist
die eigentlich keine möglichkeit zu
verlieren habe die realität ist immer
eine ganz andere
aber man muss ja nicht unbedingt bei den
programmen stehen bleiben sondern man
kann ja aufdröseln was die einzelnen
parteien treten in diesem fall grüne und
die cdu/csu und da ist schon eine partei
die grünen eine partei der sagen wir es
mal nicht den demokratischen lenkung des
staates hand ermöglichen bürger steht
hingegen einem programm das er darum
sich nicht so wahnsinnig unterscheidet
von dem was die cdu csu immer gemacht
hat keine partei die möglichst viele
bälle möglichst freie entscheidung
einbinden will
und die problematik ist mehr nehmen die
welle es mehr ab dass er die sagen wir
die grüne thematik die natürlich bei den
grünen genetisch von handel ist aber die
grünen heftig auch integriert in sein
anderes programm sein
liberalkonservative programm
das ist die frage und darf ich
ganz kurz rtl einen realitätscheck
zitieren
in der schweiz gibt es starke grüne die
haben null gewonnen in letzter zeit
gedacht grünliberale das ist ein
besonderes phänomen und vor zwei wochen
also eine volksabstimmung über drei
absolut grüne voller nämlich realität
verbot eine wasser vorlage für die
landwirtschaft und co2 lenkungsabgabe
und da waren die großen parteien die
sagen wir verantwortungs parteien
schließlich war die schweizerische half
den am und cvp raus die waren dagegen
die waren dafür
und alle drei vorlag wurden abgelehnt
zum schrecken ich war selber verliere
ich habe dreimal ja gestehen
das wurde abgelehnt und dann kam und das
ist der ganz interessante realitätscheck
im realitätscheck
wer hat vor allem diese vorlage
abgelehnt
die jungen leute und das ist eine
aussage darüber dass die menschen
irgendwo etwas sagt haben
fribourg satthaben gegängelt zu geben es
kann auch ein reflex auf dieses jahr von
corona sein aber sie haben es irgendwie
sagt ich war erschrocken sagt was ich
denn da los
gute leistungen von eurem namen das
abgelehnt das ist realitätscheck gut wir
nehmen den ball auch gleich noch mal auf
dann dieses thema spielt ja im
bundestagswahlkampf auch eine rolle noch
mal ganz kurz zu den beiden
wahlprogrammen wenn man das der union
ließ dann hat man tatsächlich das gefühl
das ist ja eher für ein bündnis mit der
fdp geschrieben
das wird zwar jetzt nicht für eine
schwarz-gelbe koalition mutmaßlich
reichen am 26 september aber ist das der
richtige eindruck die das genau an diese
politische richtung damit der fdp haben
wir sicherlich insgesamt mehr
schnittmengen dass da würde ich ihnen
völlig zustimmen aber das programm ist
vor allem auf grundlage der
unionsparteien geschrieben und das was
unsere politik auszeichnet wenn man eben
über das thema klimaschutz gesprochen
und da ist uns ganz wichtig dass wir
nicht nur sagen alles soll teurer werden
und alles soll verboten werden sondern
uns ist wichtig dass wir auch an die
sozialen folgen denken dass wir es mit
einer vernünftigen arbeitsplatz politik
kombinieren und dass wir aus klimaschutz
wirtschaftsmodelle machen und das hat
die union immer stark gemacht dass sie
diese großen fragen der zeit mit
wirtschaftspolitik verbunden hat und
gleichzeitig mit einer sozial und
arbeitsmarktpolitik ich habe ja gesagt
wir kommen wir gleich noch konkret drauf
weil an diesem beispiel lässt sich das
besonders gut machen
die umgekehrte frage ist sozusagen an
sie das wahlprogramm das bündnis 90/die
grünen veröffentlicht weil das ist
eigentlich eher für eine koalition auf
jeden fall mit der spd und vielleicht
noch in teilen mit der linkspartei
geschrieben das programm das bündnis 90
die grünen verabschiedet hat ist ein
angebot an bürgerinnen und bürger und
die werden entscheiden wie stark sie die
grünen und die themen und die angebote
die wir machen am ende machen warum
geht's und nicht um nur koalition oder
die frage habe ich mehr sympathien für
den einen oder die andere und wir sind
in einer situation in der wir vor ganz
großen herausforderungen stehen allen
voran die bekämpfung der klimakrise sie
ist die existenzkrise unserer zeit und
die grünen bündnis 90 die grünen haben
den anspruch so wie alle anderen
parteien im demokratischen spektrum hier
ein angebot zu machen das klima zu
schützen sozial und gerecht und vor
allen dingen gemeinsam mit dieser
zukunfts herausforderung soziale und
ökologische transformation und mein
eindruck ist nachdem ich jetzt das
cdu-wahlprogramm gelesen habe dass teile
der wirtschaft viel weiter sind als die
cdu/csu in der versöhnung der
verankerung programmatisch von
ökologischer transformation und
notwendigkeiten die wir haben bei der
umstellung der wirtschaft wenn wir die
klimaneutralität anstreben dann braucht
es eine veränderungen dann können wir
nicht mit rezepten aus den 80er jahren
wirtschaftspolitik weitermachen
und da sagen wir ja da sind sie ziemlich
blank im hinblick auf
klar gemacht wo die unterschiede liegen
machen da auch gleich bevor wir jetzt
sozusagen in diesem bereich eintreten wo
da der an diesem beispiel wo dann der
unterschied liegt und wer da
möglicherweise richtiger liegen kann
noch eine erinnerung an das jahr 2017
haben sie eigentlich gute erinnerungen
an das jahr 2017 an dieser jamaika
sondierungen vom spätherbst 2017
denn das muss ja zwischen ihren parteien
relativ gut gelaufen seien der schurke
der da vom hof gefahren es war ja
christian lindner gewiesen also ist das
noch ist das noch etwas worauf sie
vielleicht möglicherweise nach der
bundestagswahl anknüpfen könnten also
man hat gesehen im jahr 2017 dass die
fdp noch nicht bereit ist zu regieren
und dass die fdp auch verantwortung
scheut und das ist glaube ich etwas was
die fdp bis heute auch in sich trägt und
weswegen auch viele bürgerliche wähler
sagen werden
wir machen das kreuz bei den
unionsparteien weil wir immer bereit
sind verantwortung zu übernehmen und
nicht nur von der zuschauertribüne aufs
spielfeld um 9
aber ich würde sagen wir dürfen die
großen herausforderungen in den nächsten
jahren nicht mit diskussionen der
vergangenheit hin und wir müssen nach
vorne schauen
daher würde ich nicht immer ins jahr
2017 zu dieser wahl sind sich heute
nicht mehr so nahe wie 2017
es geht nicht um nähe es geht darum wie
man verhandelt sehr ernsthaft als
bündnis 90 die grünen wir wären bereit
gewesen alles auszuloten um inhaltlich
programmatisch eine große koalition
abzulösen
denn in 16 jahren regierungszeit merkel
haben wir jetzt das zwölfte jahr große
koalition das tut einem land nicht gut
das war unser anspruch seiner zeit aber
wir sind jetzt vier jahre weiter deshalb
an einem ganz anderen punkt wir haben
auch die globalen herausforderungen die
pandemie situation und die klimakrise
situation alle haben sich verschärft und
erfordern an ganz entschlossenes handeln
und deshalb sehen wir einen ganz anderen
u 20 21 uhr münchen was wenn man das von
der beobachtungsstation außerhalb der
parteien sich ansieht
gerade jetzt beim thema klimaschutz und
den parteiprogrammen oder einstellung
den wahlprogrammen die grünen sind ja
relativ konkret was die finanzierung
angeht auch die zeit punkte die
reduktionsziele und so weiter bei der
union ist das nicht so ganz deutlich
manchmal etwas vage funktion formuliert
könnte es aber trotzdem sein dass dieses
etwas vage formulieren die bessere
taktik für einen wahlkampf ist wohl das
thema klimaschutz für viele wichtig ist
und vor allen dingen jetzt auch
interessant wird wenn es ans zahlen geht
also man könnte schon den eindruck haben
dass vielleicht sogar die unionsparteien
also erstens das tun was sie immer
machen nämlich durchaus um konkret zu
sein weil man ja viele leute ansprechen
möchte mehr breitere milieus als dass
die grünen wollen aber man könnte schon
auch den eindruck haben dass die union
auch von der diskussion gelernt hat die
über das grüne parteiprogramm oder
wahlprogramm geführt worden ist den
grünen wurde ja der vorwurf gemacht als
sie ihr wahlprogramm veröffentlicht
haben dass da zwei konkrete ziele
benannt sind das aber unklar bleibt wie
man das eigentlich konkret finanzieren
möchte da ist von vielen fonds die rede
da ist im grunde unklar wie genau wer
wann eigentlich was finanzieren soll
da ist im grunde ja eigentlich auch der
ansatz dass man das grundgesetz die
schuldenbremse die sogenannte
schuldenbremse zumindest lockern möchte
nicht aufgeben möchte aber lockern
möchte
das wiederum hängt natürlich davon ab
dass man parlamentarische mehrheiten im
bundestag aber auch im bundesrat hat die
überhaupt eine grundgesetzänderung
ermöglichen also insofern ist auch bei
den grünen vieles unklar in deren
wahlprogramm das sind die ziele
konkreter formuliert das stimmt aber die
grünen haben sich eine diskussion nach
der veröffentlichung eingehandelt ja wie
wollt ihr das finanzieren und das kann
man dem programm nicht genau entnehmen
und aus dem grund komme ich zu der
feststellung vielleicht haben die
unionsparteien ein wenig sich das dann
auch zur zur lehre gemacht und haben
gesagt wir bleiben relativ
bestimmt das eröffnet uns andererseits
aber eben auch wieder die möglichkeit in
mancherlei hinsicht dann tatsächlich
anschluss fähiger zu sein zu den
unterschiedlichen parteien natürlich in
beiden wahlprogrammen gibt es auch
fixpunkte die sich zunächst mal
unvereinbar lesen beispiel ist zb das
tempolimit aber auch da gibt es
vermutlich ernährungs möglichkeit meyer
sie haben wir uns gerade am beispiel der
schweiz erklärt wie eine eigentlich
ökologie affine bevölkerung drei umwelt-
und klimaschutzmaßnahmen abgeschmettert
hat in einer volksabstimmung man kann ja
sicherlich die schweizer gesellschaft
mit der deutschen durchaus auch
vergleichen
wie konkret ist es denn gerade im
bereich klimaschutz oder wie sinnvoll
ist es im bereich klimaschutz sehr
konkret zu werden und damit auch
erwartungen zu wecken die man dann ja
auch erfüllen muss ist die ganze klappt
übrigens die grünen stehen ja nicht nur
für die klima aber in der klimapolitik
trifft man ganz intime bereiche der
mensch dass wir dort nicht überlegt man
hat ja diese schicht die da aus dem
kreißsaal über den hörsaal in den
radfahr und vielleicht sogar in den
minister sein will
sie hatte keine ahnung von den ganz
normalen leuten was für die das auto
bedeutet also heißt ja selbst das auto
ist ein freiheits instrument denn ganz
einfach und sollte den 13 bewohner mit
zwei kindern sind manchmal in 2 das ist
ein eines dann dieses gängeln dann die
heizungen teure machen dass daraus ich
sag noch mal ich habe dafür gestimmt
aber die nicht begriff das ja kaum dass
ich ja wie soll ich sagen kostenmäßig
für mich nicht relevant aber nicht weiß
wie relevant das ist und das war wie ein
nein nein nein nein und das licht das
ziel kollegium das heißt arbeiten
das sind arbeiten und diese
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter für sich mit
doppelpunkt sagen
die während sich für etwas und die
grünen kommen da nicht so richtig
geraden das könnte noch eine machen der
bühne geben und jetzt komme ich zufällig
die offenheit die cdu/csu dies
integrativ aufzunehmen denn der gedanke
ich ja richtig die grünen haben ja hier
irgendwo ein geburtsrecht das recht der
ersten geburt mit dem grünen thema aber
dies aufzunehmen und zu integrieren das
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger ansatz und
ich sehe nicht warum herr lasche nicht
glaubwürdig sein sollte in dieser sache
ich meine nachdem die grünen 16 jahre
praktisch bettvorleger von frau merkel
fahren können sie ja nicht sagen das war
halt dann damals schon nicht gut und
jetzt machen wir sagen sie
damit regiert stimmungsmäßig total
mitregiert und laschet wird das mache
ich jetzt wieder auf einige komponenten
drin gewesen der vorwurf an die grünen
ist ja einerseits sie würden zu wenig
die sozialen konsequenzen den
sozialausgleich in der klimapolitik
berücksichtigen und es gibt auch
umfragen dass wir eine ganze reihe von
menschen
der klimaschutz gar nicht der wichtigste
wahlkampfthema ist ist das dann so ein
medienhype auch gewesen mit denen die
grünen da relativ gut erst mal in der
ersten jahreshälfte zurechtkamen der
aber doch so an den interessen der
menschen etwas vorbeigeht nein davon bin
ich ganz überzeugt sie können doch aus
einer nachwahlbefragung in
sachsen-anhalt bitteschön nicht ableiten
dass das thema klimaschutz nicht die
höchste relevanz hat in sämtlichen
umfragen ist das so und auch im hinblick
auf die junge generation ist es noch so
wir sollten uns auch entscheiden über
die volksbefragung in der schweiz
diskutieren da bin ich nicht so firmen
oder ob wir über die situation in
deutschland lösen schlieren umstimmung
ellen schulz hat nur sagen eben mit
blick auf dieses land hier ist es nicht
so dass die grünen hier regiert haben
wir sind 16 jahre in der opposition
wir haben eine sehr kritische
konstruktive opposition gemacht wir sind
dann 11
bundes in elf bundesländern an
regierungen beteiligt deshalb einfluss
genommen über den bundesrat und
bundesrat entscheidung an relevanten
stellen warum sage ich das weil wir
nämlich längst an einem punkt sind herr
meier wo solche beschlüsse schon gefasst
worden sind wir haben gemeinsam mit cdu
und spd im bundestag und im bundesrat
längst diese frage co2 preis und
kompensation beschlossen und das
traurige war vor zwei wochen öffentlich
und das ist auch ein bisschen feige
gewesen dass cdu und spd
spitzenkandidaten sich plötzlich daran
nicht mehr erinnern
längst hatten wir den mechanismus co2
preis 25 euro beschlossen und zwar
gemeinsam und trotzdem veranstaltete
olaf scholz mit dem benzinkanister in
der hand in der bild zeitung die große
geschichte der benzinpreis darf nicht
steigen und armin laschet hatte
hinterher dass auch er das so sieht aber
ganz sicher gewesen war längst gemeinsam
im bundestag beschlossen und ich hätte
erwartet dass die beiden parteien und
ihre vertreter
dazu stehen und sagen so ist es in aller
ernsthaftigkeit wir haben das gemeinsam
beschlossen und das hat folgende folgen
für die fossilen trägern lkws hat wenn
ich das ausführen darf zu ende haben wir
entsprechende entlastungsmaßnahmen
geplant im hinblick beim
bundesratsbeschluss auf die
pendlerpauschale und die absenkung der
eeg umlage
wir als grüne sind die einzigen die
bisher im programm sagen es braucht eine
pro kopf rückerstattung an die menschen
ein energie geld wenn wir im hinblick
auf die co2 preiserhöhung weiterarbeiten
damit klar ist dass es eine entlastung
für bürgerinnen und bürger gibt
der prozess war ein bisschen dreist von
der union auch von der spd dagegen das
glaube ich nur um einen cent
preisunterschied bei der
benzinpreiserhöhung durch den co2 30
eigenen dafür vermöbelt worden die
grünen in diesem wahlkampf sie haben
sich ein bisschen hinter den grünen
versteckt haben wir mit der spd
praktisch das gleiche beschlossen
überhaupt nicht wir achten darauf dass
was auch herr meier ihrem geschildert
ratsbeschluss dass wir wieder nach unten
als wir achten als union frau hatte man
darauf dass wir alle bevölkerungsgruppen
mitnehmen weil klimaschutzpolitik wird
am ende nicht erfolgreich sein wenn nur
die besserverdiener im land sich
klimaschutz leisten können das haben die
ersten hier ist das haben wir in ganz
vielen ländern europas gesehen und wir
wollen die gesellschaft nicht spannend
wir wollen sie zusammen führen daher ist
unser ansatz vor allem über seine reise
zu dem was die grünen die heimischen
fans wir haben aber ihr ziel haben 25
euro sie waren wir federweißer wir sagen
doch aufstehen wir haben ja auch schon
wir haben doch im bundestag auf
beschlüsse gefasst und wir haben jetzt
in unserem wahlprogramm doch ganz klar
gesagt wir wollen eine co2 bepreisung
und wir wollen im gegenzug strom
günstiger machen das wird der
entscheidende hebel sein damit sich bei
der rhi getrieben elektromobilität
durchsetzt damit sich wasserstoff
durchsetzt damit sich synthetische
kraftstoffe bei der senkung der
strompreise wären die grünen ja auch
mitmachen ich hab ja ich denke wir haben
gesenkt werden sollen
wie gesagt das den sturm zu senken es
werden auch noch mal einen wichtigen
punkt machen
auch bei der diskussion auf feld und das
ist auch der geist den das
regierungsprogramm der unionsparteien
atmet wir sagen klimaschutz ist ein sehr
wichtiges thema ich habe eben auch
unsere punkte kurz dargestellt
aber wir sagen es gibt auch sehr viele
andere wichtige themen und es gibt nicht
nur ein thema es gibt zum beispiel sehr
viele leistungen sag ich dann noch zum
ja immer eine letzte frage stellen ihr
können auch auf andere themen darüber
wenn sie jetzt sagen in dem wahlprogramm
soll verkürzt sie sind für den
marktwirtschaftlichen ansatz verknappung
der zertifikate der preis soll sich auf
dem markt bilden wenn das nicht
funktioniert dann müssen sie aber
trotzdem staatlich regulieren denn so
frei ist auch die union ja nicht mehr in
dieser frage es gibt ein ziemlich
eindeutiges urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
klimaschutz zu den klimaschutzzielen
das heißt notfalls müssen sie dann auch
zur staatlichen regulierung greifen das
was die grünen ja
wir sind aber überzeugt dass die
marktwirtschaftlichen instrumenten die
besten sind wir haben gesehen dass wir
in den vergangenen jahren die
klimaschutzziele für 2020 auch mit
marktwirtschaftlichen instrumenten am
besten erreicht haben und wir glauben
dass wir zum beispiel durch
investitionen in wasserstoff durch
investitionen in e views durch
investitionen batteriegetriebene
elektromobilität diese ziele erreichen
werden
ich glaube auch dass wir die pariser
klimaschutzziele nur so erfolgreich
erreichen können weil wenn wir einen
nationalen alleingang machen der im
fahrverboten endet oder der daran ändert
dass man nicht mehr fliegen darf
dann wird kein anderes land der welt
diese klimaschutzpolitik nachahmen und
was wir schaffen müssen ist dass wir
technologien in deutschland herstellen
die andere region in der welt übernehmen
und das wird auch in china in den usa
und anderen ländern die klimaschutz
ziele erreichen und das ist dann wäre
der union
herr meyer ganz kurzen satz ich würde
mich kann hier breit machen mai aber nur
ganz kurz mit ja da hatte ich es wäre
ein riesen anliegen
wir haben es mit einer historischen wahl
zu tun und zwar möchte ich das zeigen an
einem beispiel die sozialpolitik die
verwandlung der quasi kapitalistischen
welt in eine soziale geste auch aus
anstoß von der linken kräften sehr
ideologische kräften aus dass säkulare
religiösen kräften die kommunisten die
linksextreme um die verantwortungs
parteien die demokratische wie die cdu
csu wie die freien demokraten um die
sozialdemokraten haben diese sache
aufgenommen und über geführt in einem
allgemeinen konsens und haben dann
angetrieben von den radikalen kräften
eine vernünftige sozialpolitik gemacht
und genannt das muss jetzt passieren
dass man sagt okay die grünen sind ganz
wichtig aber es müsse die verantwortung
parteien die auch nichtjuden und sagen
über und ein neues deutschland wie augen
oder jetzt hat sondern sagen nein dieses
westlicher deutschland die saison
jahre wird auch eine klima republik das
müssen die verantwortung teilen
übernehmen und dass ich das ist die
auseinandersetzung die jetzt stadt
bilden
gut jetzt geht es aber auch um die frage
vielleicht deswegen würde ich auch gern
noch auf ein anderes thema in dem
zusammengehören kommen von münch ist ja
jetzt viel auch von sozialen
gesprochenes wort von verantwortung man
über sie da immer dann in dieser
diskussion das sind ja dann drei
parteien um die es da geht bei einem
möglichen schwarz grünen bündnis die csu
ist da ja auch noch dabei wenn man jetzt
mal die begriffe wie wertkonservativ
umweltschutz die csu nenne sehr oft
bewahrung der schöpfung ansieht das sind
begriffe die sowohl von den
bündnisgrünen als auch gerade von csu
politikerinnen und politikern im mund
geführt werden
trotzdem tut sich die csu mit der grünen
besonders schwer gerade in bayern da
haben ja bei der letzten landtagswahl
die grünen auch der csu viele stimmen
abgenommen
liegt da eine weitere konfliktlinie und
was ist das für eine zwischen csu und
den bündnisgrünen ich würde ehrlich
gesagt diese konfliktlinie zwischen csu
zumindest zwischen der csu führung und
den grünen für gar nicht so groß halten
also ich gehe davon aus dass der
csu-vorsitzende söder einem bündnis mit
den grünen einiges abgewinnen kann ich
glaube nicht dass er da die gesamte csu
hinter sich hat aber leider scheint das
für durchaus reizvoll zu halten
da ist er der unterschied zur
parteibasis das interessante ist ja um
dieses thema angesprochen diese
wertegebundene ökologische politik und
die ist in der csu die das natürlich
auch für sich in anspruch nimmt bezieht
sie sich eher auf dieses thema
umweltpolitik also da geht es dann um
den schutz der natürlichen gegebenheiten
der schöpfung
darauf bezieht sich dann eine christlich
konservative partei die hat bis jetzt im
grunde dieses thema klimapolitik dass
man hier unterscheiden muss vom thema
umweltpolitik und das miteinander zum
teil ja auch fast schon im widerspruch
steht
klimapolitik felder csu deutlich
schwerer weil da verändert sich
landschaft da verändert sich auch die
sichtbare umwelt mit dem tut man sich
schwerer bei in sachen umweltschutz wie
gesagt das sehe ich da gar nicht so weit
von den grünen entfernt
da denke ich mir manchmal dass laschet
sich vielleicht schwerer tut der eher
richtung gelb also richtung fdp bringt
als das vielleicht die csu vor hat was
soll man wenn wir auf beide parteien auf
union und auf die bündnisgrünen sehen wo
sehen sie denn da überschneidungen wo
wäre auch kompromisslinien für die für
die grünen bei möglichen
koalitionsverhandlungen wo ist die rote
linie die die grünen in keinem fall
überschreiten würden
also jetzt geht es darum dass jede
partei im demokratischen spektrum für
sich und seine ideen und projekte wirbt
und das ist der status gerade wir leben
doch nicht in einer gesellschaft wo man
jetzt sagt ich baue mir mögliche
konstellation am liebsten so dass sie
sich machen warum hinsteuern ich meine
termine schloss mixa aber danach
ergebnissen dann macht und dass wir am
27 september sehen wir werden dann sehen
wer erster kraft geworden ist im
demokratischen spektrum wir kämpfen
darum zum ersten mal in unserer
40-jährigen parteigeschichte und
anknüpfend an das was frau mit gerade
gesagt hat unser leitmotiv bei gründung
der grünen war wir haben die erde von
unseren kindern nur geborgt und das in
der hinsicht auf die ökologische frage
und die soziale frage und da will ich
nochmal anknüpfen an das was wir vorhin
aufgemacht haben nämlich die
sozialpolitik im cdu programm ist kein
sozialer ausgleich vorgesehen
im hinblick auf die frage der
notwendigen beschlüsse beim
ordnungsrecht bei der frage förderung
bei der frage innovation und
investitionsoffensive da gibt es keine
entlastungsvorschläge bis auf die
pendlerpauschale und sie wissen ganz
richtig für sie wissen aber ganz genau
deren wirkungsweise oder müssen wir die
erklären
heute da mal für viele leute auch als
dass sie nur mit einer pendlerpauschale
besser gesagt nur mit einem eigenen auto
auch einen arbeitsplatz haben
pendlerpauschale ist das eine ich sage
nur wir mit unserem energie geld
entlasten auch die die von der
pendlerpauschale überhaupt nicht
betroffen sind und wir müssen uns wenn
wir weiterhin auf diesem pfad gehen und
das müssen wir bei der frage 1,5 grad
ziel
dann müssen wir uns für die breite der
bevölkerung für die menschen ein angebot
machen die entlastung und da haben wir
die konzeptionelle idee des energie
geldes so was fehlt bei ihnen komplett
die sensen punktuell an einzelnen fragen
an aber machen in der breite für die
menschen kein angebot ich finde aus
sozialpolitischer sicht auch
problematisch dass sie den menschen
versprechen dass wir steuersenkungen
machen
wir sind in einer so dramatischen
situation finanziell nach der pandemie
dass ich mich frage wie soll das
gelingen
wir wissen dass wir jede menge
investitionen brauchen wir haben zum
beispiel im bereich der kommunen da wo
das leben stattfindet wo bürgerinnen und
bürger ihr lebendiges gemeinwesen
empfinden soziale und kulturelle fragen
da haben mir 147 milliarden euro
investitionsstau wir wissen interessiert
wie schuldenbremse so ausgereizt und
überreizt haben wir können doch in so
einer situation den menschen nicht sagen
wir senken die steuern da sieht man
genau die unterschiede oder das gucken
wir mal wie's weiter unter tat sieht man
genau die ihnen die gründe ist ja die
steuern werden erhöht zwar den
vermögenssteuer oder das halten wir für
den großen fehler sie wollen alle steuer
senken aber die ausgaben steigern und
wir haben 480 milliarden euro in diesem
jahr schulden aufgenommen
also man kann an den ausführungen von
die gasse man den großen den großen
unterschied zwischen union und den
grünen passieren
welche ausreden lasse ich habe ja eben
auch zugehört also was sie wollen ist
weitere massive ausgaben des staates zb
durch ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
haben wir haben sie haben weitere sie
haben weitere diverse ausgaben
beschlossen milliardenschwere das sagen
ja auch ihre eigenen parteifreunde das
kann glaube ich niemand bestreiten wir
wiederum sagen wir sind jetzt schon
weltmeister bei steuern und
sozialabgaben also der staat hat kein
einnahmeproblem
der staat hat aber teilweise ein
ausgabenproblem und er hat ein problem
die gelder zu verbauen
und deswegen haben wir in unserem
programm zum beispiel auch wichtige
punkte drin wie eine beschleunigung von
infrastrukturprojekten wenn wir 20 jahre
im durchschnitt brauchen für ein neues
projekt dann ist das einfach
inakzeptabel und deswegen haben wir auch
da reform maßnahmen vorgeschlagen wie
zum beispiel eine digitalisierung der
verwaltung oder auch dass wir an das
verbandsklagerecht rangehen weil es
nicht sein kann dass teilweise verbände
im land wichtige infrastrukturprojekte
beklagen die wir zur stärkung des
wirtschaftsstandortes brauchen aber auch
zur erreichung der klimaschutzziele und
wir sagen wir wollen vor allem
wirtschaftswachstum schaffen wir wollen
fesseln lösen und damit auch neue
steuereinnahmen generieren und das ist
unser ansatz und ihr ansatz ist
eigentlich nur steuern zu erhöhen und
diejenigen auch noch zu bestrafen die
morgens aufstehen hat arbeiten sich um
die familie kümmern und nie und diese
gruppen wollen wir viel stärker in die
mittelposition sagen wir wollen
wirtschaftswachstum generieren das kann
man sicherlich durch steuersenkungen
oder anreize für unternehmen machen nur
hinter uns
zu diesem wachstum muss es ja auch erst
mal kommen zunächst mal ist es eine
mathematische frage sie wollen steuern
senken ausgaben erhöhen vor allen dingen
bereich digitalisierung haben sie gerade
gesagt gleichzeitig wollen sie die
schuldenbremse wieder einführen die
schwarze null wie soll das funktionieren
sie das geld nur einmal ausgeben können
sie vermindern die einnahmen erhöhen die
ausgaben wollen aber gleichzeitig die
schuldenbremse zurückfahren
also zumindest so wie ich rechnen
gelernt hat komme ich da auf keinen
grünen zweig
das wird schon gehen wenn man ein
starkes wirtschaftswachstum schafft das
habe ich ja immer auch erklärt
das muss auch wieder reinkommen das ist
ja einfach genau aber wir aber wir
hatten jetzt durch die krone
diese eine ausnahme situation vor der
korona krise sei es ja auch schon sehr
gut aus wir hatten sehr gute haushalte
dank der unionspolitik und dank der auch
schuldenbremse und der finanzpolitik und
wir haben doch gezeigt dass man die
schuldenbremse einhalten kann und
gleichzeitig auch eine starke
volkswirtschaft haben kann und das wird
auch genau der ansatz danach der korona
krise sein dass wir sagen wir wollen
schwerpunkt legen auf investitionen in
die infrastruktur
das macht den wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland attraktiv lockt investoren
an und wir wollen die große frage
klimaschutz im wirtschaftspolitisch
sehen und glauben dass wir zum beispiel
indem wir deutschland zum wasserstoff
land nummer eins machen hier auch
hunderttausende neue arbeitsplätze
schaffen und das ist eben das was das
unions programm auszeichnet dass wir
diese ganzen großen themen miteinander
verknüpfen und dass deswegen auch eine
entlastung der hart arbeitenden menschen
überhaupt nicht im widerspruch steht zur
erreichung der klimaschutzziele und zu
anderen wichtigen kritisch haben jetzt
beide werde ich deutlich gemacht hat sie
eigentlich eine völlig unterschiedliche
politik betreiben wollen
offensichtlicher nicht nur im wahlkampf
ich habe jetzt mehrfach gefragt wie das
denn danach wird und was sie dann
vorhaben da sind das ist jetzt erst mal
wahlkampf wir kämpfen nur für uns aber
nach der wahl werden sie ja viel von dem
was sie jetzt hier verkündet haben
wieder zurücknehmen müssen denn egal in
welchem bündnissen sie sind sie müssen
kompromisse machen da wird das ganz
anders aussehen dann was bei rauskommen
das was ich vorhin als realitätscheck
bezeichnet habe ist das nicht ein
problem für die parteien insgesamt dass
sie immer sehr viel versprechen müssen
und dann ihre wähler und anhänger
verteilen wenn hinten nach vielleicht
noch nicht mal die hälfte bei rumkommt
ich finde wir haben sehr realistisches
programm formuliert
für bündnis 90 die grünen mit sehr
konkreten projekten und ideen zum
beispiel steht in unserem programm kein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen machen so
gern partei deutlich lustig machen sie
den popanz jetzt nicht auf wir haben die
kindergrundsicherung als projekt denn
wir können uns nicht damit abfinden dass
jedes fünfte kind in deutschland in
armut lebt und wir haben eine idee
entwickelt für eine garantie sicherung
die das jetzige sogenannte hartz 4
weiterentwickelt oder ersetzt
das ist der
ihre frage im hinblick auf die frage
bündnisse oder wie geht man in den
wahlkampf im wahlkampf wirbt man für
sich und seine ziele und danach macht
man selbstverständlich deutlich und das
machen wir auch jetzt schon dass wir mit
allen demokratischen kräften reden
angesichts eines wahlergebnisses wie die
bürgerinnen und bürger entschieden haben
deshalb gibt es auch im hinblick auf die
demokratischen kräfte keine
ausschließeritis keine lagerbildung oder
sonst etwas und das finde ich sehr
vernünftig wehrmann bürgern gegenüber
sagt das und das sind die ideen und
vorschläge von bündnis 90 die grünen
wir bitten sie darum wir machen ihnen
ein angebot machen sie uns möglichst
stark damit wir viel davon in einer
konstellation umsetzen können wir werden
mit allen demokratischen kräften im
deutschen bundestag reden und ausloten
wie die situation nach dem 26
dabei würden das mit der linkspartei
noch ausschließen und sie wollen ja
keine ausschließeritis glaube ich allen
demokratischen kräften gut diese
diskussion machen wir jetzt in dieser
rechnung nicht noch auf zur linkspartei
aber frau münch die parteien sollen also
im wahlkampf den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ein angebot machen jetzt nehmen die
dieses angebot an und wählen dann die
jeweilige partei weise sich davon am
meisten versprechen und dann kommt
danach eben zu dem was wir
koalitionsverhandlungen nennen und
kompromisse und rote linien setzen die
parteien da immer relativ sicher und mit
einer gewissen zuversicht auch auf die
vergesslichkeit ihrer wählerinnen und
wähler paar wochen vorher um das dann zu
akzeptieren dass es eben tatsächlich
nicht so wird wie die parteien ihnen das
im wahlkampf ja eigentlich versprochen
haben aber gleichzeitig natürlich dass
frustriert wähler zumindest die
stammwählerschaft aber gleichzeitig
haben wir jetzt nun viele jahrzehnte
gehabt als deutsche bundesbürger zu
lernen dass wir eben
koalitionsregierungen haben wir haben
auf bundesebene noch ein
die eine alleinregierung einer partei
gehabt wir hatten immer
koalitionsregierungen das problem
besteht im grunde darin aber wenn wir
eigentlich kräfte haben wie bis jetzt
union und spd so genannte große
koalitionen
die in einem starken wettbewerb
eigentlich ursprünglich mal standen die
zueinander finden müssen dann sind die
leute unzufrieden weil dann der parteien
wettbewerb im grunde entkoppelt wird und
die leute sind mit etwas unzufrieden was
sie aber in der summe als wählerinnen
und wähler selber produzieren wenn
nämlich die parlamentarischen mehrheiten
zu knapp sind und wenn im grunde
womöglich sogar drei bis vier parteien
bündnisse und koalitionen geschmiedet
werden müssen
mit partnern die eigentlich sich selber
nicht wirklich über den weg trauen das
macht die wählerschaft unzufrieden aber
da muss man gelegentlich natürlich der
wählerschaft auch die rückmeldung geben
dass das etwas ist was man bei den
parteien vor der tür ablegt wir als
wähler in der gesamtheit und die
parteien müssen damit zurechtkommen die
suchen sich das ja nicht heraus diese
kleinen bestimmen pakete die eben große
koalition bündnisse womöglich sogar drei
oder vier koalition erforderlich machen
also insofern da ist die frustration
vorprogrammiert insofern sollten
parteien schon gelegentlich auch mal die
wählerschaft daran erinnern dass das zu
unserem regierungssystem aufgrund
unseres wahlsystems einfach dazugehört
ohne koalition wir haben jetzt noch
knapp 33 minuten hier in der sendung
sind bitte ich darum etwas kürzer
antworten herr meier
man sagt ja jetzt auch wenn man armin
laschet in den letzten monaten oder
wochen muss man ja sagen also sich jetzt
da gefangen hat und offenbar auch die
union wieder stabilisiert hat wenn man
ihn genau man sagen dass er verfolgt was
er vorhat das sei eine fortsetzung der
merkel jahre mit anderen mitteln aber
doch ein eher ein weiter so würden sie
dem zustimmen
ich würde mal hin bloß sagen dass jetzt
digitalisierung und weil der körper wie
viel modernisierung nötig ist ist ja
nötig aufgrund von 16 3 mm jahr unter
der kanzlerin problems sich 16
eingeknickt sind die werte besser
gewesen sie hätten
mal richtig kritisiert da für die grünen
die damit gemacht haben
aber selbstverständlich ist rasche
jemand mehr kam mit andern und übrigens
hat der musste sich nicht erholen hat
sich durchgekämpft gegen sollten
gelegentlich umfragen gegen das ganze
mediale getue meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen da dachte man den mann ist
erledigt nein der ist da mit kraft
reagiert ein land mit 18 millionen er
macht es nicht schlecht also was ist
denn da gegen die kanzlerkandidatur
sondern ich meine hexen rhein und der
stadt was er tut worauf die bürgerinnen
und bürger zählen können er kam er kann
mit den grünen ihr könnt ihr am besten
mit der fdp
es wird das hat er ja auch gezeigt wobei
der vielleicht darf ich das noch
erweitern in der frage an sie weil sie
auch mal als durchaus ein freund von
schwarz grün wie kommen sie denn
persönlich mit mit mit laschen auftritt
klar ich komme aus nordrhein-westfalen
kennen natürlich armin laschet ich
wollte aber zu allen meyer sagen herr
meier seien sie versichert am ende
entscheiden die bürgerinnen über das
angebot nicht nur über das wahlprogramm
sondern auch über das personelle angebot
und wir haben mit annalena baerbock als
kanzlerkandidatin und dem spitzenduo
robert habeck und annalena baerbock ein
sehr gutes angebot das sich sehen lassen
kann unser plus ist mit dem angebot
werden wir das angebot das angebot
laschet ich weiß nicht haben sie ihnen
von anfang an unterstützt hat er gegen
friedrich merz und gegen so dass sich
durchsetzen müssten also zensiert sie
hatten ja werten der union wirklich
herausragende kandidatin das habe ich
auch wenn es immer wieder mit fünf aber
auch und was armin laschet wirklich
ausgezeichnet hat ist das eher ein
enormes stehvermögen hat das zeichnet
auch einen sehr guten kanzler aus und
dass er neben wichtigen themen wie
klimaschutz und wirtschaftspolitik vor
allem auch für eine klare
migrationspolitik stehe die illegale
migration bekämpfen möchte und legale
migration verteuern brauchen alle
olaf scholz haben wir hier gar nicht
angesprochen möglicherweise kein zufall
aber stehvermögen für anderen hamburg
und für armin laschet dann werden wir
weiter sehen wir verfolgen das hier
natürlich ich bedanke mich bei
hesselmann bei christoph ploß hier im
studio bei ursula münch und bei frank
meyer bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]